and no one did the link person that got
close was you but sound like a good time
sure I didn't really end out his store
only fine yeah I don't think I did
honestly Shen huh you grew up in America
no I was born in Korea you were born in
Korea when I came here when I was like
three okay okay hey boy come here Jim
what do y'all want to show you something
but when he sits something on your chin
yeah you ever see oil come out of one of
these things you don't got this in Korea
do you champ
no he cool real Korea we do a little
differently down here cuz you can the
chin you don't take one on your chinny
chin chin sign no yes sir bend over
chance Shia LaBeouf had to Chennai to
help him help me put on my boots put on
my Buddhist and chin goes home he make
me put on his parents like what do you
make you do he showed me his oil stick
what he's all your stick what did he
make you do chin he making me taste his
oil
I believe chin was it you know why
because talking to charity like American
American I'm gonna show you some let me
take you around town you hungry boy
you're like pancakes
oh yeah I record the pancake we got we
got syrup
this is special syrup down here for what
time was it that was it Dallas where
it's the Central Texas oh no no not now
no this is it right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]